still talking to your friends it's
complicated
many when we first got together we were
different people the game by Eddie
Antony
this is a Martha and Bethany the
suspense grandfather meet you
morning sergeant on you you're not
barging he's barging my little Walker
yeah did you guys see Spencer Vicki went
back in we gotta go get him
[Music]
huh
what oh you oh my god you're Spencer's
grandfather
are we in Florida and you Milo Walker
did I turn into some kind of a small
muscular boy scout are we dead it sure
feels good now look at my thighs okay
you have some issues here the game is
busted who's the game I'm not yet I
don't wonder yet
welcome to Jumanji
this next venture is even more
challenging and remember the future of
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji is
that barbers boys we're gonna die we did
are we in hell and
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is to suit your strengths
and weakness's smoldering intensity it's
this stupid face you make huh he's going
on you having a heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down
you